the story that we are going to tell you
begins in Germany around
forty years ago
at this time when our
grandparents were getting married and decided
for example to go on their honeymoon to
Paris. They encountered many
obstacles before  'reaching the city of
lights was
not a small matter,
both had a series
of valid visas on their passports,
yet when crossing several
borders he was subjected to real
interrogation, they were asked, for
example, if he had not
smuggled into France  Bavarian butter
or Viennese sausages or
other rarities subject to customs duties
the journey was long and difficult
fortunately there was Paris at the end
to reward them the barriers
which still exist today
will only exist tomorrow in the
textbooks of  history and we will have forgotten them, let us
still pay homage to our
grandparents and their heroic times
and let us be happy that the peaceful
European family of our time
finally lives in a world that is a little simplified
for the traveler who travels through Europe
and 6 c on geography maps that
the notion of border persists paris
ram amsterdam luxembourg bonne and
brussels are practically the big
cities of one and the same country a bit
like in the time of charlemagne the great
european community under construction is
erasing national barriers  a
new idea has become the objective of all the
peoples of this part of Europe
common future unities and well-being the
best minds have been concerned
for a long time with this idea of ​​a
European community
and this has found its basis in the
Council of the  Europe which brings together almost
all the countries of Western Europe
in general cooperation in the
economic, social and cultural fields
politically however progress
despite certain successes has been slow we
have often remained on
Christmas wishes and the magnificent projects have
slept in  their boxes there was an
exception the Schuman plan of this plan was
limited to a few very
specific objectives but it aimed high and far
progressively without forcing steps
the plan established a method
of economic integration proving by
its success and that it could
apply to the entire economy
the sector of the Schuman plan was that
of coal and steel
the long-term objective encompassed
political and economic European integration
in a progressive movement the six
enemy countries of war  and freshly
reconciled signed a treaty the coal
and steel on the pillars that we drive in a
in this European sense still marked
by conflicts
with the help of this raw material with which
we had formerly forged weapons we
built the great idea  of the
European community peace building
to be clear let's say that the
construction contract was signed on April 18, 1951
the architect was Robert Schuman
French Minister of
Foreign Affairs and the achievement of this goal
received the name of European
Coal and Coal Community  steel abbreviated these cases
this experience was to prepare the
fusion of national economies and
lead to the political unification of
countries in a word rival nations
were to unite into a sort of large
family animated by peaceful intentions
is resolved to work  in common and
today the problems of coal and
steel appear as
ancient history
the ratification of the treaty in July
1952 marks the completion of the first
building then we built the
European community
we enlarged the building to  house the
atomic community there and we will
now bring everything together under the roof of
the European community
but the first plans of the
parent company the Ceca determined the style and
construction of the whole they
proved and timing of the political mergers
it is through union that the aim is
most quickly and best achieved the
european coal and steel community
the first union achieved between
holland belgium luxembourg
france italy and the
federal republic for  a market like coal
and ore, scrap metal and
steel, concern for national interests
leaves little room for concerns about the
prosperity of common areas but as
national barriers disappear, discriminatory tariffs,
land quota obstacles and
Massène subsidies production
becomes less expensive and more profitable
now despite
national borders have brought the coal
necessary for steel from the nearest mine
and no longer as in the past from a
distant mine under the pretext that it is
in the  same country and in this space
practically without borders, the
species of coal and steel are
suddenly experiencing great
development
but as you know, the progression of
trade lowers the cost of
production
so that the common market takes
real momentum,
we are going to eliminate the duties
internal customs and
reciprocal import quotas
so production is now cool
under the same conditions throughout the
European territory and no longer
only in the country of origin,
subsidies of all
kinds as well as price advantages are abolished
granted to exports to prevent
internal prices maintained at an
artificially high level from making it
possible to subsidize the
exports of an uncompetitive industry,
all
restrictions on
international payments within the
common market were eliminated, tariffs were standardized
railways throughout the
country
restrictions on the
movement of labor have been removed and
jobs have become vacant for
qualified workers
regardless of their nationality the aim
of all these measures is to create a
European economic order  new to
make free competition reign within
a space without borders
the company was original it
required both protection and
support took care to avoid on the one
hand
that agreements and understandings were
concluded to control the market  because
agreements and concentrations that are too
powerful are often hindered by
agreements on prices and production restrictions,
natural evolution and which under the
pressure of free competition encourages
productivity
on the other hand the specialization of
certain companies and the  merger
of other unprofitable companies
makes it possible to rationalize
production that they find a more
favorable framework for its expansion in the vast
space that has been opened to it the new
economic order of the ceca therefore ensures
a policy of prices and agreements
new is healthy it establishes
fair rules suitable for the entire
extent of the common market
now agreements are prohibited
concentrations must serve
the general interest and are therefore
subject to authorization
during the first ten years more
than 200 cases of  suspicious cartel on
examined by the ceca concentrations
on approve or reject guarantees
were demanded the european
coal and steel community was the
first european organization to
take such measures and to enforce them
throughout the territory in  despite
national borders
in fact the members had undertaken to
renounce their sovereignty with
regard to coal and steel and
transferred, so to speak, the exercise of
public power to a higher authority
the high authority it was  a true
peaceful revolution above the
governments of the different countries,
a European government was thus created,
an autonomous body which
now had certainly limited
but real powers allowing it to develop
and monitor the common market. This
body was even controlled by its
own parliament and its  own court of
justice
in addition a council of ministers
deliberating on
general problems ensures the safeguarding of
legitimate national interests high
authority council of min
european parliament court of justice all
this constitutes an innovation in
international law we also created a
European tax the first of  gender
the seca levy this levy these
cases currently represent 0.2
percent of the value of
coal and steel production 2 per thousand but
it is one per thousand have made the
new supranational community institution
financially
independent from governments  all
this was achieved gradually in
five years and on January 1, 1958, the date
of entry into force of the treaty establishing
the European Economic Community,
the transitional period of the ECSC was
practically over.
Experience has shown that
the true national interests are  we can
understand each other very well even when
we speak four different languages
in this new wide open spaces we
produce more and more economically
than ever during the first ten
years of the common market in coal and
steel
the types of goods have  almost
tripled while the average price of
steel increased by 16% in
Great Britain and 24% in the United States,
it increased by only 3% in the
community,
thus the common market was asserted,
sales were increasing and  and prices
remained relatively stable
the scale of this new market and the game
of competition stimulated
the industry which began to practice
a bold policy
of investments supported by loans
from the high authority of the ceca in 1963
industries  coal and steel
devoted 9 billion francs,
twice as much as in 1954, to the
modernization of their installations and
new acquisitions.
Steel production increased from 42 to
73 million tonnes, or around 80%.
growth more rapid than
in other spaces and than half the
while the share of the United States
in world production regrets this
from approximately 41 to 27% the
European coal and steel community
retains an unchanged share  of 20% with
a fifth of world steel production
the Swiss ceca today at the level of
America and the Soviet Union
between which it takes its place by its
exports they are even ahead of them the
ceca is today the  largest
steel exporter in the world
ore extraction was centralized
on profitable businesses and
increased by more than 20% in the
community
scrap metal recovery doubled
room coal production did not
keep pace with the  general expansion
it has decreased quantitatively
by around 6%
because where previously coal was
almost alone in providing energy,
today
natural gas and especially oil are used more and more
throughout the world.  of
production exceeded the possibilities
of disposal the supply of energy
became surplus and in
many parts of the world
this resulted in a crisis in
coal sales crisis which still lasts the ceca
then was able to prove itself in a way
which should serve as a model
in fact within the community
rich countries and countries poor in coal are
in the same boat
despite their
fundamentally different economic interests Belgium for
example with its numerous mines which
often operated in the past in
conditions that were not at all profitable were
particularly  tested by the crisis,
we produced too much and did too much, Italy
on the contrary does not have, so to speak,
a coal deposit worthy of the
name,
so it had no worries in this
regard instead of being handicapped by the
support of coal mines  nationals it
could buy coal at a much lower cost
in the United States in fact in
France in Belgium in Germany
mountains of unsaleable coal
piled up on the mines
at the height of the crisis in 1959
stocks had reached 30 million
tonnes in  Belgium
the coal crisis threatened to
spread to other branches of the economy
the ECCA intervened in May and all the
member states were not yet ready to
entirely subordinate their
national interests to the common interest so
Germany took the following measures
Belgium decided to curb their
imports of coal from
third countries
at the same time the mines whose
operation was no longer profitable
especially in Belgium were closed
which reduced the country's production by a third
thus Belgium and is isolated
for a certain time
from the rest of the common market by
restrictions placed on
coal trade which gave the industry in
crisis
the possibility of reconverting the
affected regions beneficiaries of
abundant credit which were used to
reorganize to rebuild
the industry and to  helping and rehabilitating
workers thanks to a retirement in
good order
we managed to avoid the catastrophe which
threatened the coal crisis
then transformed into a recession
organized without social shocks thanks to the
brake given to
overproduction and imports
from third countries
and despite the reduction in needs,
stocks gradually fell from the 32
million tonnes accumulated in the
mines, only
11 million remained in
1963, since 1953
the number of miners has decreased
by around 250  thousand thanks to the credit of
the ceca they were professionally
rehabilitated and found another job
on the other hand the improvement of the output
and the modernization systematically
encouraging obsolete installations
caused a
considerable increase in productivity
thus the output went from one
ton and a half to more than 2 tons a
third,
an increase of around 60% per
man and per shift
but despite better
productivity,
coal continues to decline the
reason is that other sources
of economic energy ensure  a
growing share of the supply and that
the European economy if they lie a
few decades ago still
the production of energy was only
a matter of tanks of water
today on the contrary we have
very large quantities  of various
sources of energy which replaces
coal hydraulic energy
natural gas mainly oil and
very recently atomic energy a
carefully drawn up estimate for
the year 1975 demonstrates to what extent
in all probability
the supply of the common market  in
energy will be transformed over the
years to come,
energy needs will then have
tripled and it appears that coal only has
about a quarter left; the
majority of our needs
will therefore have to be covered in the
coming years, especially by
oil imports
later it will be nuclear energy
which itself will provide the complement
Europe must not remain on the sidelines of
this development
it risks being eclipsed economically and
politically for two
essential reasons too high cost of its
energy  and insecurity of a
supply dependent on
imports
but such a development must not take
place in disorder
it must be carried out methodically within
the framework of a European energy policy
it must allow the
coal industry to
gradually adapt to the  new
market situation faced with competition from other
forms of energy and ensuring it the
best possible chances of
development because even in the future
coal will remain, if only
for security reasons,
it will remain one of the bases of
the supply of Europe with
energy thus the horizon broadens
formerly energy was synonymous with
coal today energy is
coal plus a certain number of other
sources of energy the
coal economy has made  place for the
energy economy contributed to the programming
of a common energy policy
this is today the latest of
the tasks of the oldest
community
the ceca which made possible the merger
of the six countries into a
European economic and atomic community  and which
far beyond prepares a
complete integration of their apps on the
economic, cultural and political levels